Jake in st. Charles Missouri you're on
the bench P Rochelle go for Jake hey I
was wondering if you could give me some
advice I've been my wife works for a
company who she's surrounded by
co-workers who are pretty openly liberal
and they tend to do a lot of open
commenting about bashing Trump bashing
Republican ideals and you know it's it's
kind of she she's friends with them but
she doesn't want to you know have it
affect her professional status at the
company
yeah so I just wanted to see is there
anything you know you would advise me to
tell her as far as how she can navigate
that situation and you know without Jake
it's rough I mean the fact is that
conservatives are constantly put under
the sort of pressure at work my wife she
happens married to a very prominent
conservative as it turns out and for
years she kept it quiet at her at her
work like working with doctors and
nurses she kept it quiet for years that
I was her husband and if she mentioned
if she was asked what I do should say
well you know he's he's in politics or
he's a lawyer or something you know keep
it pretty vague because the blowback in
mentioning conservative politics is so
strong what I will say is that ignoring
the blowback is a mistake that you sort
of have to decide on your priorities so
it's possible it's quite possible that
your priority is speaking out and being
in a career where you feel comfortable
saying what you can say working in a
business with people who are not going
to punish you for saying what you're
going to say it's also possible that
your career aspirations require you to
subsume your your sort of political
opinions to keep them to yourself hey
pal I really believe that generally the
workplace should not be a place for
politics I'm annoyed that there are so
many people on the Left who don't
believe that we generally don't talk
politics
publicly in this office really right in
my office and I run a political
organization I don't talk about with my
producers because we're doing the show
every day but when I'm just walking
around the office I'm not spending a lot
of time talking about Donald Trump or
Barack Obama to random members or staff
well it's just not something that really
is done it's very irritating let's
assume that they get to talk whatever
the kind of crap they want to talk and
that everybody else is supposed to shut
up I think exactly I was kind of
wondering how there's a double standard
there it seems like they feel that they
can speak out openly and there won't be
any repercussions if there you know
support the left but if
the intimidation is incredibly strong
and also conservatives tend to be a lot
less litigious they they tend not to be
the ones who go to HR if they're
offended by something and people on the
Left who very often will go to HR you
say something political and next thing
you know they've gone to HR and the
company being afraid of legal liability
is always going to give all of the
grease to the squeakiest wheel it's
certainly do recommend the other going
gate would you recommend her going to HR
on her behalf if you know what do you
think that would backfire you know
typically I'm not a fan of going to HR I
mean just generally and that's not me
speaking up as an employer I just think
that if I were an employee you're going
to HR rarely results in exactly what you
want from HR you're then well well it's
true that you are that you are catered
to to a certain extent the company
starts to see you as as a problem
honestly if the workplace is that
uncomfortable you got to look for
another workplace or you have to just
acknowledge that this is gonna be a
place where you don't have politics or
you can say to people listen I'd really
prefer to talk about something else
let's just shift the topic Jake really
appreciate they called Matthew you're in
Louisville Kentucky
go for it Matthew hey Ben I'm a big fan
I appreciate it go for it sir although
although I'm a Trump supporter who do
you think has the best chance of beating
him in the 2020 election and Republicans
should be most worried about I mean I
still think that the person that the
Republicans should be most worried about
is Biden namely because the best thing
Democrats can do is run a dead body
really look I think they should run a
corpse if they could actually like find
Bernie not Bernie Sanders like weekend
at Bernie's Bernie and then just staple
a wig on him and prop them up and roll
them around on a dolly and have them run
for president I think that is their best
option because if the election is a
referendum on Trump as a human being
Trump is in trouble if the referendum is
on the Democrats and their policies the
Democrats are in trouble and Biden is
the closest thing to a sort of default
candidate he doesn't have any really
hard political positions he's very much
mouth about what he believes and what he
is going to do
he doesn't promise huge systemic change
the fact that he's a bumbler and a
Stumbler and old and and it makes him
non-threatening so it's actually an
asset like all the things that make him
a liability in the primaries make him an
asset during the general election now
does that mean he's gonna win no I mean
the man is vulnerable on a wide variety
of scores but if I'm the Trump team I'm
much more concerned about Joe Biden
running than I am about Bernie Sanders
who can eat I mean making the election
referendum on Sanders is easy
is pi I mean that is just simple and
doing it on Warren is similarly I think
simple so I people most worried about
Biden awesome Ben thank you so much I
really appreciate it Matthew thanks for
the call Pete in Las Vegas you're on the
bench be Rochelle go for Pete
I appreciate it's my wife's pregnancy
but we are we were I was definitely
involved at least in the inception and
and at the conclusion I will be more
involved I think so well I hope so we
talk about music for just a second sure
and you recognize the violin lovely of
God I became the premium member when you
endorsed the Doobie Brothers and Steely
Dan on yourself oh yeah I'm the favorite
pop acts and so I wanted into them oh
man I mean I would love to sit in with
those guys
again I think that it's very difficult
in the music world to get anybody to sit
in with you if you are not on the same
page politically I don't know where
those guys are politically but the
blowback of having me on stage to play
with some rock band I think would be
extraordinary I mean the dennis prager
my friend Dennis Prager actually was
supposed to conduct the thing is the
Santa Monica Symphony over at Disney
Hall and there was such a blowback from
the from the orchestra that it turned
into a national controversy and I was
conducting an orchestra I can't even
imagine a high profile band allowing
somebody like me up on stage who played
like Ben Folds will play with people who
to judge but I think it's gonna be a
while before anybody allows me to play
violin with them on say listen they
wouldn't allow condi rice play piano
with them on stage either so Pete I
appreciate they call will in Roseburg
Oregon
you're on Ben Shapiro sure I'll go for
well hi it's a pleasure to meet you I'm
a gigantic fan I just wanted to say a
few things about me real quick I'm 30
years old I'm married with six kids I'm
a trade worker I'm a welder and like I
said I am from Southern Oregon there's a
big liberal just heir of the entire
state and so my question is what can I
do in particular with the current state
of my of how my state is going currently
to ensure that my children and my family
and all the other families like mine can
make money and live comfortably without
worrying too much about all the
stupidity coming from Portland all the
other parts of Oregon that
more power now well it's it's really
difficult I mean I've lived in a leftist
state my entire life I've lived in
either California or I was in Cambridge
Massachusetts for three years and and
the fact is that I think every day about
moving out of the state I mean it's a
serious consideration because this state
has become such a trash heap the taxes
are so high the chances that the state
is ever going to recover are basically
no and so you're seeing people flee I
don't know that Oregon is in quite the
same state there have been sort of at a
local level there are more Republicans
in Oregon particularly Southern Oregon
actually there are a lot of
conservatives in Southern Oregon that
people don't think about but the fact is
that as these states polarized as blue
populations multiply and red populations
leave things are gonna get worse and
worse I would always have a bag packed
well I mean I'll be honest with you I
think that the country is gonna get more
divided before it comes back together
because there has been a significant
attempt to divide the country
along political and philosophical lines
I don't think it's gonna be anytime soon
the best you can hope for is control of
your local government that at least
protects your values but once that
collapses I'm not sure how much there is
we'll really appreciate the call in just
one second we'll get to more of your
calls at eight five five two three six
32:28 first got to tell you about
something I am doing it this year so a
few years back many years back now
because I'm getting older I got my
braces off and what I did my
orthodontist like where are these
retainers and all will be well and that
lasted for like a year and then the
retainers were gone and I have never
worn retainer since and then my teeth
started moving around they start
actually clashing with each other you
start getting little chips if your teeth
start moving around that way and so now
I have signed up with cans and I'm using
their retainers them using their clear
aligners on a regular basis candid will
actually deliver a clear aligners
directly to and straighten your teeth
for 65 percent less than braces
unlike braces canids clear aligners are
comfortable removable totally invisible
so you can transform your smile without
anyone noticing a thing plus you never
have to set foot in a doctor's office or
a waiting room your treatment is
prescribed remotely by a licensed
orthodontist and can--it delivers
everything you need directly to your
door unlike other companies candid only
works with orthodontist never general
dentists which means your treatment will
be designed by an expert in tooth with
20 years of experience on average if you
have a special event this year it is a
perfect time to get those teeth aligned
and can and can do it for you quickly
and easily you can do it from the
comfort and privacy of your own home if
you're ready to take the first step
toward straighter teeth now is the time
check out candid co.com slash man that's
candid co.com
slash been use code been
seventy-five bucks off so you get a
great deal candid co.com /ban code been
candid co comm / been use a code been
and you get 75 bucks off Randy in New
York around the Ben Shapiro show go fart
Randy uh yeah I just had a question for
you about the impeachment trial going on
sure go for it um my question is is the
entire thing is based on obstruction and
abuse of power and my question with that
is does that same principle apply to
Congress as well as the presidency yeah
it absolutely does I mean I would assume
that if a congress person is guilty of
abuse of power or obstruction they could
be brought up on impeachment charges now
there have been members of Congress
who've been brought up on such charges
before it's usually an ethics charge
that starts off in the ethics committee
maybe they're impeached or they resign
but sure I mean you wouldn't actually
have to commit a crime in order to be
impeach that's why the the argument that
crime always has to be attached to
impeachment is not is not true with that
said do I think that members of Congress
are ever held to the same standard as
the president when it comes to the sort
of stuff particularly president from I
doubt and Maxine Waters is one of the
people presiding over this trial and
Maxine Waters I mean she she's awful
Maxine Waters has been deeply corrupt
for decades in the number of deeply
corrupt members of Congress is
significantly higher as a percentage
than the number of deeply corrupt
presidents that we've had Randy really
appreciate your call let's see right in
Ohio you're on the bench pure I go for
it Ryan yeah how's it going man hey Jim
pretty well go for it sir nice yeah so
you know me and my buddy see all of you
and we're all kind of wondering when
there's gonna be a Ben Shapiro for
president dude it sounds awful I mean
honestly I have a great job and a great
life nothing sounds worse to me than
getting on the road 24 hours a day and
either dragging my family around with me
my wife and now almost three kids and
getting them on the road or abandoning
them and doing that
nothing sounds worse than having to try
and pander politically which is what all
these folks tried to do that'd be the
only fun of it honestly would be getting
on the road and then just saying
whatever I wanted and it worked for
Trump so I don't see why it couldn't
work here but the job itself also seems
deeply miserable because honestly like
if you're the president
the best thing you can do is make
yourself irrelevant the best thing you
can do is just minimize your presence
and make your office less powerful and
slice and dice the executive branch and
basically your only job becomes to
defend the country I'm very much in the
mold of Calvin Coolidge when it comes to
what the president ought to do governing
what I really enjoy doing is talking to
people about ideas and you really don't
get to do that very much as president to
the United States so what I ever to do
it I mean the the let's put it this way
these circumstances dictating that I run
for president would have to be so
overwhelming that I would have almost no
choice in the matter
but do what I want to do that he'll know
it sounds awful then people tear apart
your life and spend all their time
digging up crap on you and if you're an
honest person and you try to spend any
time doing any sort of reflection about
yourself then you end up doing what I've
done right I have like a full list
online of things that I think that are
dumb that I've said over the course of
the last 20 years but they'll always dig
up something else and you can spend your
life worrying about that or you can go
live your life and be comfortable and
enjoy your job so I don't know Ryan it
sounds sounds absolutely terrible
appreciate thanks very call Ryan alright
let's see who else Michael in Wisconsin
you're on the bench Shapiro for Michael
hi Ben big fan I just want to say thank
you I got my left is tears tumblers it's
great I was going to send you one cuz I
work as an engraver but I don't have an
address for a fan mail I appreciate it
may be my producer can get you one Oh
that'd be beautiful my question for you
is based on all of the stuff that tom
Fitton has been coming out with with
judicial watch all the stuff about ship
obtaining new uses emails illegally and
all this others like background dealing
going on why isn't the administration
simply just countersued based on that I
mean for defamation maybe a good start
so Michael the public information law is
that defamation law is extremely
demanding if you want to file and win a
defamation lawsuit slander or libel you
actually have to prove because the
president's is a public figure you have
to prove malicious and malicious is a
really really high standard so willful
and maliciously lying about somebody to
take an example Jerry Falwell sued I
believe it was hustler magazine way back
in the day and the case was that hustler
magazine had printed a cartoon that
showed Jerry Falwell I believe slipping
his mother in an outhouse or something
right this is hustler magazine and
Falwell she
this is not correct and the court said
well that's not malicious okay that's
not malicious I don't know the hell is
malicious
so the standard for public figures is
extremely extremely high also right now
the agenda of the administration is just
to get this thing over with and move on
to the 2020 race and I think that
anything that lengthens this process is
likely to be a waste of time and or a
bad idea so that is that I think is why
the president hasn't sued yeah but
listen I wouldn't rule anything out the
president has not been shy in his
threats to sue although he's not filed
nearly as many lawsuits as he has
threatened over the course of his career
Michael really appreciate the cop coming
up we're gonna take four more of your
calls at eight five five two three six
32:28 that's eight five five two three
six thirty two twenty eight so now is
your opportunity to get on the line ask
me a question this is the Ben Shapiro
Joe
[Music]
[Applause]
you